buonasera e un grandissimo piacere
essere per me qui ho sentito queste
storie bellissime ma voglio provare a
raccontarvi anche io una delle mille
visioni di un futuro possibile
il futuro che stiamo cercando di
raccontare tutti questa sera qui
parto con una storia con la mia
esperienza da ragazzo anche io come
alcune delle storie che abbiamo sentito
ero particolarmente appassionato
dall'informatica e avevo una visione
chiara del mio futuro
avrei fatto qualcosa che c'entrava con i
computer e allora da ragazzo alle scuole
superiori
avevo soltanto un grandissimo problema
mio padre non voleva assolutamente
comprarmi un computer perché pensava che
non sarei andato poi bene a scuola non
avrei studiato mi sarei messo a giocare
e allora a scuola coglievo tutte le
occasioni possibili per andare nell'aula
di informatica e con la complicità del
mio professore di matematica e fisica
stavamo insieme sperimentavamo
lavoravamo al computer
io ero felicissimo spesso veniva a
chiamarmi anche durante le altre
versioni bussava diceva collega mi serve
antonio per un progetto didattico e io
felicissimo andavo con lui cosa facevamo
insieme costruivamo una bbs era un
sistema che faceva parlare i computer
tra di loro
collegato lì con un modem e così le
persone potevano scambiarsi documenti
informazioni programmi scolastici
era bellissimo l'abbiamo fatta proprio
bene insieme
però il nuovo problema è successo che
non si collegava nessuno perché era
troppo presto i nostri i miei compagni
non avevano ancora il modem a casa e
così un primo grande insegnamento che
non c'è un innovazione senza
condivisione inutile andare troppo
avanti troppo presto se poi gli altri
non sono con te allora abbiamo comprato
con dei soldi della scuola 10 di questi
modem abbiamo portati in libreria in
biblioteca e così speravamo che quando i
ragazzi
basterà prendere un libro potevano anche
portare a casa per una settimana il
modem
questo è successo il nostro esperimento
andò molto bene eravamo contenti ma di
lì a poco internet avrebbe cambiato
tutto e quindi questo lavoro che avevamo
fatto l'abbiamo subito trasformato
abbiamo fatto il nostro sito e facevamo
le cose lì io sono andato più avanti
ho cominciato a lavorarci con internet
fare un mio sito a provare a fare esiti
degli altri a comprare dagli stati uniti
e rivendere qui in italia stava si stava
verificando quello che era il mio sogno
lavorare con l'informatica è infatti il
quinto anno delle superiori
vado da mio padre gli dico sai devo
aprire la partita iva perché ho dei
clienti
noi dice ma sei assolutamente pazzo
finisci il tuo percorso di studi
e se otterrà il massimo dei voti
apriremo la partita iva
lo faccio succede ci riesco
e da questo mix tra sfida merito ma
soprattutto passione un professore
mentor e un ambiente favorevole la
scuola mi sono diventato imprenditore la
scuola mi ha fornito un occasione ma
tutto il resto dovuto imparato da solo
le competenze per fare un'impresa
purtroppo oggi la squadra non le dà io
credo che nel nostro futuro ci sarà
molta più impresa a scuola e molta più
scuola dell'impresa a questi due mondi
si devono parlare assolutamente bene e
forse per il mio percorso che da sempre
ho cercato di aiutare le scuole a
diffondere la cultura d'impresa
dell'imprenditorialità e mi sono spinto
anche un po più avanti diventando
business angels e quindi aiutando le
start up investendo e supportando le per
provare a non fargli fare gli errori che
avevo fatto io sì perché vedete sento
troppo spesso una frase che i giovani
sono il futuro
io non credo che gli uomini sono futuro
io credo che sono il presente
noi non dobbiamo aiutare i giovani a
trovare una loro strada
noi dobbiamo costruire questa strada
insieme con loro ed è una strada che
peraltro non serve solo gli uomini ma
serve proprio a tutti
e proprio sul tema di giovani e futuro
voglio raccontarvi una seconda storia
una seconda esperienza
stavolta non un'esperienza individuale
che riguardava me la mia
il mio sogno la mia azienda ma una
esperienza collettiva
qualche anno fa mi sono avvicinato
all'associazionismo e sentivo il bisogno
di confrontarmi con i colleghi
imprenditori e diciamo trovato questo
stimolo in confindustria
dopo poco tempo ne sono diventato il
presidente e sapete quando ci si
presentano un elettorato bisogna
presentare un programma solitamente un
passaggio formale invece noi abbiamo
voluto dargli un grande significato
abbiamo riflettuto tanto sul futuro
della nostra città cosa potevamo fare
noi da imprenditori giovani per la
nostra città e quindi abbiamo
incominciato a pensare che la nostra
città poteva fare il tifo per chi fa
impresa doveva fare il tifo per chi fa
impresa
volevamo costruire un ecosistema
favorevole a chi volesse intraprendere
dove le opportunità possono circolare
veloci essere colte dai giovani
pensavamo un nuovo paradigma economico
per catania ci voleva un modo semplice
per pirlo che abbiamo coniato questa
formula
noi volevamo che la nostra città
diventasse una startup city e quindi la
formula e giovani più territorio uguale
sviluppo
bella la formula efficace bisognava
metterla in pratica è bastata la nostra
prima presentazione in pubblico
il nostro primo progetto lo sportello
per la creazione d'impresa ed è successa
una cosa straordinaria le forze della
città le forze attive rive si sono
avvicinate e ci hanno detto ci piace
questo progetto facciamolo insieme
e allora altri giovani associazioni
start up istituzioni enti mondo
universitario
insieme abbiamo trasformato un progetto
che era di una parte della città in un
progetto molto più vasto il progetto
della startup city decine di eventi in
questi anni progetti network supporto
alle idee che volevano nascere
competenze è stato ed è un percorso
meraviglioso un percorso che
ci fa ottenere grandi risultati perché
la cosa bella di un percorso di comunità
che questi risultati si possono
monitorare nuove aziende che si sono
aperte nuovi posti di lavoro che si sono
creati tanta effervescenza ed entusiasmo
in città e anche nel momento in cui un
grande player nazionale come working
capital ha scelto una città nel
mezzogiorno per aprire l'acceleratore
una casa dell'innovazione ha scelto la
nostra catania è stato davvero un
percorso un percorso bellissimo e credo
che il nostro futuro
queste comunità quelle che i nostri
amici di reina chiamano le comunità del
cambiamento avranno un ruolo sempre più
importante
credo che le persone unendo le loro
passioni le loro competenze e la loro
voglia di cambiare le cose con
semplicità potranno fare tantissimo e
credo che una delle storie che potremmo
raccontare molto presto sarà quando
queste community cercheranno di essere
più forti insieme e provare a crescere
costantemente insieme e andare avanti e
quindi vi ho voluto raccontare queste
due storie per raccontarvi come come
immagino il futuro c'è però un ultima
cosa che devo dirvi l'avrete notato no
c'è una palla qui è per noi un valore
molto importante perché questa palla è
il simbolo della nostra community
ed è l'elemento totemico che racconta
questa frase questa bellissima frase di
john cage ma things a mistake there is
no women of the holy mail
questa è tutta la sintesi di quello che
vi ho detto finora
il futuro lo possiamo immaginare
possiamo sperare di raggiungerlo ma
soprattutto ci dobbiamo lavorare da
subito e ci dobbiamo lavorare insieme
nel basket
se entro 30 secondi l'azione non è
finita
la palla passa all'altra squadra
purtroppo la nostra cultura se pensiamo
al nostro sport più diffuso il calcio
possiamo anche vedere una partita di 90
minuti e non si segna neanche un gol
finisce 0 a 0 sono due approcci
completamente diversi noi siamo per
l'approccio del fare e quindi in
acceleratorio quando facciamo degli
eventi c'è sempre una palla che
simboleggia
questa azione questa responsabilità chi
parla ce l'ha in mano e poi quel gesto
più se invece possibile lo diciamo anche
come luogo comune ti passo la palla ma
noi la passiamo fisicamente e
responsabilità dell'azione passa
un'altra persona io credo che oggi qui
non ci siano soltanto mille persone
quello che vedo io sono mille visioni di
un futuro possibile e allora io questa
partita del futuro vorrei provare a
giocare la combo e vorrei provare come
faccio da me a passare la palla
ora non vedo bene ma ci proverò c'è una
persona che dovrebbe ricevere e vi dico
perché voglio giocare questa partita con
voi perché come dice il mio amico
riccardo luna nel futuro
accendiamo tutti o non ci per nessuno a
voi la parola grazie